well if you remember the crash of 2008
and nine when everyone lost all their
retirement remember that well if you
haven't read about remembering it it's
because it didn't happen you didn't lose
all of your retirement even if you
cashed out at the lowest possible point
of the stock market's movement you lost
half of your retirement you didn't lose
all of your retirement the Dow Jones
Industrial Average has its high point
prior to the Great Recession before
everything came to an end and the
chicken little was running around get a
helmet the sky is falling before all
that stuff happened the Dow peaked out
at about 14,000 it dropped by March of
2009 from a high of 14,000 in the fall
of 2008 it dropped to about 660 394 so
basically went in half and of course
everyone was running around like I've
lost all their money and what do you do
in the market when the market when the
clout when the economy collapses and the
economy didn't collapse economy dropped
artificially low and recovered very
quickly so then you know the question is
how quickly does it get back to 14,000
from there from 2009 s low is right
around 2012 took about three years for
it to come all the way back so if you
put money in at the high point it went
in half and you didn't take it out about
two and a half years later you were back
to even if you put money in at the low
point you had doubled your money in two
and a half years a hundred percent
return in two and a half years roughly
yeah
why am i bringing all this up because
today Wednesday the Dow Jones Industrial
Average is closed for the first time in
our history over 23,000 okay so I went
from 14 down to 6500 6300 whatever it
was back to 14 where is it now
23,000 you won divided 23 by six that's
four times your money if you didn't get
out and do you know what I was telling
people when the market was diving you
can go back and listen to the tape she
can listen to the podcast go back pull
up pull it up this in the archives I was
telling people do not cash out your
retirement no one gets hurt on a roller
coaster except those that jump off ride
it ride it ride it the American economy
is not destroyed it is not going to
implode we are not gonna your stock the
stock market's not gonna be worth
nothing if it does the government's
gonna collapse and we've got bigger
problems in your retirement ride the way
ride the wave ride the wave write it
down and write it back up if you did
your retirement is worth four times
right
now your investments in mutual funds are
worth four times what they were at the
bottom will it go down again yes
ride it a one gets hurt on a roller
coaster except those that jump off
that's how this works
23000 the dow sets a record today
sounds like the economy is doing pretty
good this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]